it is hot up in here McBee dosa well not
even know what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] means
minty Rosa who are you peppers going on
YouTube now recently and been brought to
my attention that there is a movie
coming out or is out called Aloha now if
you know me and you have watched my
videos you guys do know I love Hawaii so
when I heard about this ship I got high
or as the Hawaiians would say cheap
hoorah for my white folk out there
that's pidgin slang that's PID GI n
which stands for something where um uh
what the [ __ ] when I don't know what I'm
talking about sometimes I just get mad
ha and well of course naturally because
I was hyped about the film I looked into
it and it turns out the very talented
Emma Stone is gonna be playing the lead
female role ooh not already from that
fact alone it only sounds pretty good
right but as I was reading further into
it it turns out that she's gonna be
playing the role of yes an Asian girl oh
no my friends you did not miss him she
is going to be playing an Asian yes my
friends a blond-haired blue-eyed girl is
supposed to play the role of a [ __ ]
racial asian girl in Hawaii yes and I
know there's gonna be a few of you out
there that's gonna see this in a very
positive and wide angle where you're
going to say well she is part agen or
half asian so there's a possibility but
yeah she could play the part but of
course those of you who say that I do
have to ask you are you [ __ ] stupid
you need to do the world a favor get a
[ __ ] battery attach the ends of it to
your [ __ ] nipples and explode your
titties off blonde hair blue I'm not a
single drop of melanin in her skin tone
constant Disney Princess frozen looking
girl is supposed to play a biracial
Asian oh my god this [ __ ] is ridiculous
for those you author who don't know who
I is a stage which I believe over half
of the population there is Asian so
you're telling me that a full white cast
is supposed to properly represent the
culture of Hawaii [ __ ] have you been to
Hawaii why people are the tourists
Asians are the
real locals [ __ ] Hawaii is
basically Asia did you know the Hawaii
has so many Asian people not a single
person ever shows up on time you can go
to a [ __ ] store and the opening hours
says Aloha bro she's not even a member
Hawaii is so Asian everything can be
haggle and discounted in that state
especially if you're a local
[ __ ] you could even handle your
hospital bill if you wanted to look at
this bill I just had a heart attack bro
okay Aloha [ __ ] Hawaii is so Asian if
you're white everything costs more for
you how much is this clothes dollars bro
excuse me how much is this forty six
dollars plus tax now get the [ __ ] out
Aloha yes there are probably a lot of
Asian people that are gonna be scattered
throughout the films and yes there are a
lot of white locals there but the point
that you are forgetting is that they
catch did a full hot white girl do play
an Asian girl so you tell me right now
when you were casting for this film
there was no Asian person of any kind of
descent that could have filled that part
has it Hollywood already has a grossly
misrepresented the Asian community as it
is this is a bit much isn't it I thought
we moved past the whole Hollywood be
when you catch somebody named David
Carradine as a bald white man you play
the role of a kung-fu master you know
what [ __ ] this [ __ ] the next time
somebody makes a Lord of the Rings movie
I want to be casted I want to have a
weird old English accent you know who
fit white people middle please pass me
the top sticks then we gonna know this
one [ __ ] why don't you get Denzel to
play a white plantation owner and by the
way her [ __ ] last name is so Asian in
this movie her [ __ ] last name is inna
she got that Chinese last name than all
the black folk in my school thought it
was short for [ __ ] what's up money
my name is in hey listen I'm not the
Hollywood Asian entertainment complainer
can you know what type I'm talking about
the quote-unquote Asian talent slash
entertainer that always complains about
Hollywood but I don't get any spotlight
in entertainment because I'm Asian
because in all honesty a majority of the
Asian people that I've heard complain
about this are the ones that usually
[ __ ] suck and yes Asian people
entertainment
it could be that you [ __ ] suck same
[ __ ] [ __ ] goes with me it's always
the people who either have nothing to
show are completely unoriginal bite off
of everybody else's [ __ ] and already
makes fun and feeds into what why people
make fun of us about to become popular
and they're the ones to complain that
the white man is keeping them down shut
the [ __ ] up you are the problem I don't
complain about being Asian if anything
me being Asian is the reason why I got
as far as I did cuz yeah I do use the
actions I do talk about Asian culture
but that's from my perspective I grew up
as an immigrant because if you gonna
make fun of us
Asians you better make fun of us the
right way but instead if we have any
film called Aloha and a state full of
Asian people played by a white girl to
represent a half asian girl listen for
me personally you love episode I loved
half the people that are casted in this
movie but you do have to realize how
ridiculous this [ __ ] is and for you to
actually expect for this [ __ ] to go
unnoticed Wow or maybe you didn't want
it to be noticed and you're just [ __ ]
stupid or you making a really stupid
joke either way try to get suck
you couldn't cast an Asian girl for this
role come on Asian people got skill son
you know this what the [ __ ] can't we do
or do even better
we are the Mexicans of the Far East we
do everything listen to the [ __ ] and I
want you to realize how stupid this
sounds you can't do a film about us and
cast us listen [ __ ] if we can
build the camera we sure as [ __ ] can be
in front of it hey what's going on
YouTube how you guys doing yes on
Wednesdays and Sundays you already know
there's gonna be your upload Wednesday's
will be a beautiful life vlog which I
hope you guys are really enjoyed because
you guys get to see and introspective
into my life
but Wednesday Sunday I will see you
again make sure you click those videos
on the left and right because they are
there for you to click yet thank you
very much I love you domo arigato come
the loudest [ __ ] helicopter well what
is this
Rambo coming through a lot we are the
Mexicans of the forest for if forest
blond hair blue eyed Hitler baby